Oh Rubik's cubes bro stander I've never
seen a trick what Ruby think either cube
you want and give it a few mixes I'm
gonna give it I'm good at that I can get
up real jet tech don't solve it yet just
mix it all right don't worry are you
ready whatever you're a little too big
huh all right it's a greeting close
let's go take a walk oh it's pretty big
all right so you missed you missed when
I mixed one I'm gonna give you my I'll
take yours all right now let's see the
very fruit let's go cheers it yes
incredible I just broke the world record
I think you are a nice man did you do
that that's unbelievable it's insane I
want to whip you with a wet towel there
we go please don't stop it sounded
erotic what was going on there that's
amazing well that's that's you know a
trick okay
lose your toe so how much have something
a little bit different now okay yeah you
personal before I do this do you want
the world record is for solving a
Rubik's Cube No take yes if you had to
guess what would be 15 minutes 15 why it
would be well I guess how much this
jacket was there like I don't know 150
there like get it right exactly
well the real answer that you incredible
it's about five seconds five seconds
it's amazing to me that's even better
than a magic trick yeah sure cuz on a
Rubik's Cube people don't realize the
number of possible combinations is so
big it's actually over 400 quintillion
that's a big number
it's a very big number there's literally
more combinations in seconds in the
history of the universe what I miss
amazing so someone could solve that in
five seconds that's unbelievable yeah
I'm not gonna try that
no I'm gonna try to solve the only with
the power of my mind okay so first of
all before I do this you mix this cube
you can see it just try mix it some more
be good it's very well I'll give it a
few more turns I get a few more turns
okay so you can see just by every color
there's green there's blue pretty much
everywhere through it yeah yeah but I
want to I want to hold your right hand
out free just like that switch but one
hand on top one hand on the bottom so
you cover it completely so I can't touch
it so put your hand up don't turn like a
girl
all right now feet do you have a
favorite color yes what's your favorite
color blue the favorite color is blue I
love it she does put
and yet you wear gray and pick it on
don't use my clothes that make me mix it
up borrow about that yeah yeah alright
so think of your favorite color blue
okay all right I'm s time that fingers
everybody to say blue blue blue
yeah that's a coincidence I just went
with that you see oh yeah okay here look
and your hands off your hands
there's no blue now right Oh blue
there's no blue only one side solve the
color blue that's that's what you know
what's gonna I went with happy pizza
yeah you've upset me